This is James Brouwer.
He lives in British Columbia, Canada.
He’s a collector.
Of records.
Photographs.
Vintage picture frames.
JAMES BROUWER: All sorts of visual imagery
and ephemera....
He also collects postcards.
They’re in these boxes.
BROUWER: And I'm sort of obsessive about this
in my collecting.
BROUWER: I like that sort of visual arrangement of
sameness, repeating itself in different contexts.
BROUWER: It could be anything from a figure
standing in front of a mountain
and you see another one with a figure
standing on a mountain
and a figure standing
in front of a field.
BROUWER: And pretty soon you start collecting
onlooker postcards.
The onlookers are cool.
But this story isn’t about them.
It’s about a type of image James didn’t
even realize he was collecting at first.
BROUWER: I think when I got home and started
more and more going through my collection
and putting images together that I'm like...
you just see it.
It’s the same sky.
In Alberta, Canada.
Redlands, California.
And Juarez, Mexico.
BROUWER:  I think what grabs in my mind is that
part of the cloud at the very far end looks
like a little mouth of a creature.
It's something your brain grabs on to.
Once you see it, the images suddenly
take on a sort of, uncanny quality.
So why would someone go through all the trouble
to make these places look the same?
This story started back in January.
When Estelle, she produces Vox Earworm
and has made some of your favorite Vox videos
sent me a link on Slack.
ESTELLE: Anyway, if you ever want to do a
darkroom on postcards… this one is cool,
it’s the same stock sky on every postcard.
It brought me to this Flickr page.
And I sent a message asking about
the same sky postcards.
I met James over Zoom.
BROUWER: I have them grouped with that
little bit of cloud facing the other direction.
BROUWER: Sometimes they shift it a little bit so
that distinctive cloud formation is sometimes
a bit off to the left or
a bit off to the right.
BROUWER: Sometimes it hugs
the top of the frame
sometimes it's more in
the middle of the frame.
There’s actually a couple of sky photos
that get repeated with slight position shifts
in James’s collection.
And it’s pretty clear that these skies
were not part of the original photos.
There’s the one James says looks
like a sea creature.
And one with a cloud that sort of reminds
me of the shape of Cuba.
Sort of.
Anyway, once I started looking
for those skies
I came across them
pretty easily on eBay
and in antique stores
in Brooklyn.
I began building my own small collection
of same-skies.
But I wanted to go see James’s
original collection.
So it was at this point that I got on a plane
to beautiful British Columbia.
Daaamn.
BROUWER: So yeah, I just started scanning them,
cropping them and putting them up on Flickr.
And now I think there's about eleven thousand
of them uploaded.
BROUWER: So there's advertising, old age homes,
windows, wax museums.
There's some really strange wax museums that
are nicely preserved in postcards
and probably nowhere else.
The bulk of James’s collection are what’s
known as “chrome-era postcards".
BROUWER: So a chrome card denotes a particular
period of postcard production, postwar,
from the late 40s through to the present, essentially,
with glossy color photographs.
And it takes its name from Kodachrome.
Kodachrome was the first commercially viable
full color film, introduced by Kodak in 1935.
These types of postcards, taken with the new
color film, circulated widely in North America
in the 1940s through the 1970s.
With branding on the back like:
BROUWER: Plastichrome, Lusterchrome,
things like that.
Always with that word “chrome.”
To denote the shine and the gloss that you
see on these postcards and the punchy color.
By the time James started collecting in the
1980s, the glossy, mid-century chrome cards
were just piled up in flea markets,
largely overlooked.
BROUWER: The postwar cards
were considered more junky.
It was something easy to collect
for the cheap.
And I’m like, sure I'll grab that.
Looks cool, looks cool, looks cool.
And pretty soon I'd amassed a lot of it.
And I don't think I ever noticed at the time
that I was grabbing the cards that had
the exact same sky repeated
in different contexts.
There’s a few things we know about
the same-sky postcards.
Namely, that they all came from the same place.
BROUWER: It appears that these same sky postcards
are all from one publishing company
Dexter Press.
Dexter Press was one of the largest
postcard manufacturers in the world
during the chrome era.
And looking into their history provides a
clue about the same sky postcards.
It was founded by this guy, Thomas A. Dexter,
in Pearl River, New York.
And, according to the back of this postcard
from National Post Card Week ‘86,
Dexter was printing 4 million cards a day
at their peak, and pioneered the so-called
“Natural Color” printing process.
“Natural Color” referred to a mechanical
process of printing postcards from color photographs.
BROUWER: So it might be that this particular
publishing company had some reason to do it.
It might be that it had a lot of visual punch
this white and the blue.
Maybe they thought that’d
enlivened the image.
Or it might have something to do with
the company's other innovation.
Dexter patented a process called “gang printing,”
which upped their printing capacity
and enabled them to take on print orders for
smaller postcard publishers.
BROUWER: Maybe they thought it was some strange
way of marking Dexter Press's visual territory.
Like a little signature of sorts
that no one would notice.
And I’m going to be honest, that’s the
explanation I was hoping we’d end up with.
That this was...
...a sort of little trademark that Dexter
would slide in to make it a Dexter image.
Do you think that's a possibility?
BILL BURTON: No.
After talking to James, I called Bill Burton.
He’s the publisher of the online magazine
Postcard History, and I sent over two same-sky
postcards to ask him what he thinks.
And his explanation made a lot of sense.
BURTON: Dexter was the go-to guy
to print chrome postcards.
BURTON: He had very large presses, and
he could print them at very high speeds.
BURTON: He had a big art department.
He would offer to photo-correct
any problems in the image.
So if the sky for whatever reason didn’t
look the way a customer wanted it to…
BURTON: The artist would cut out a mask that
would just go right up the telephone pole
and across it and down and along the roofline
or whatever it was.
BURTON: Then you would put the sky behind it and
you'd match the two of them up.
These two cards have the same image in the sky
because they had stock images of skies.
And most people wouldn't have known the difference.
I mean, who goes to a store, buys three postcards
and then grabs a magnifying glass
and looks at what they got?
Nobody.
Well there is one person.
BROUWER: And I still collect them and I still
love them and I still am
a champion of the chrome-era postcard.
Dexter Press is long gone.
And there’s really no way to know for sure
why they replaced some skies
and seemingly left others untouched.
But they probably never anticipated that somebody,
someday, would put them all together.
BROUWER: To me, it's not so much
the grand mystery of why they did it
because I think visually it creates
something really remarkable.
BROUWER: These cards that are meant to
denote a particular place...
Like Grand Teton, Wyoming.
Or McLeod’s Lake, British Columbia.
BROUWER: ...when taken en masse, the differences
get washed away and so you get
this sort of typology or type that
floats above the particulars beneath.
And these images, which are often pretty bland
on their own, transform into something new.
BROUWER: And it's very obvious with
the same sky pictures,
You've got something arbitrary, like an amalgamation
of clouds, they start repeating and gaining
a strange significance just by
virtue of being repeated.
BROUWER: It makes the card not just what it is.
BROUWER: It becomes something else.
James mentioned a couple of figures from the
art world that inspired the look of his collection.
Including pop artist Andy Warhol.
Whose wall of Campbell's soup cans and colorful
portraits of thee rich and famous, you might recognize.
And two conceptual artists I didn’t know
about, but I’m glad I do now:
Bernd and Hilla Becher.
Who photographed industrial architecture in
Western Europe starting in the 1950s.
Their whole thing was about
form and sequencing too.
BROUWER: And the beautiful way they were arranged
so that the type of imagery would repeat
with small differences in between, and just
the visual impact of that is incredible.
So I sort of wanted to reproduce that.
There’s a link to James’s full collection
online in the description of this video.
Plus a couple of links that I found helpful
if you want to do some postcard research
of your own.
Thanks for watching